I think it was when I was young like 19 or 20 that I joined a Chinese bujutsu association.
This is where I learned basics like posture, etc.
I learned what they call the kihon renko of Chinese bujitsu.
As I practiced those things,
I realized I didn’t really like performing kata.
Then I heard of another sport that came from China called Sanda.
It had close combat matches wearing headgear that included striking, kicking, punching, and throwing.
I didn’t have any experience at that time,
and I got to know someone who had mastered the combat systems in the Japan Self-Defense Forces.
I learned things like striking, kicking, and throwing from him,
but since it was personal training,
it wasn’t like the conventional training at dojo where they would learn the basics together step by step.
We rather picked certain points and concentrated on those.
We also asked for volunteers to practice with us and he told me how to move as we practiced.
He was a really smart person, his training was unique and much more detailed than the conventional training,
including how to use our body, and it was good, it really helped.
It really helped for the competitions such as Sanda.
I think it’s good to participate in competitions while you are young.
You might win or lose but it’ll be good experience anyway.
Then, there is also a koryu teacher from whom I learned a lot in terms of skills
and regarding the establishment of Aunkai.
He had mastered taijutsu and kenjutsu from his school but now that I think of it,
he didn’t have a training manual per se like basic training, kata, kumiuchi, and then taijin.
But he taught me how the human body worked technically, psychologically, and biologically, and about posture,
how I should stand, things like that.
And he told me to take that home and to practice it.
It was like that for 10 months to a year.
It was indeed a short time,
but it constitutes the essence of what we do when I teach since I created the Aunkai.
And when I turned a certain age,
I started asking myself how I would take my power and speed to the next level.
So before I turned 30, I decided to learn from a Sensei known for Daito-ryu Aiki-jujutsu.
It was very helpful too,
He taught me that it wasn’t about external forces
He taught me how to be able to use internal forces rather than something external like muscles.
Those practices are reflected in Aunkai as well.
I also learned how to use my body, more of physical technique, from masters of conventional Aikido, Daito-ryu, or Aiki.
In Japanese, we say "Aun no kokyu",
and some think of it as like the Yin/Yang from Chinese Taichi,
the InYo [陰陽], like in taikyoku [太極]
But originally, "A Un" in Sanskrit means the beginning of an event and the end of it
and that continues forever,
In bujutsu, if there is a beginning, there is also an end and there is this feeling that you have until the end, and the movement continues forever.
Through that, we create phenomena in different ways.
That’s how I came to name it Aun.
At shrines and temples also,
there are two bodies like komainu, aun or kongo rikishi or nio statues,
there are different names for them but you see two statues in front of shrines or temples.
So deeply in the Japanese history, there is also a meaning, and I think that’s why they have those statues.
Well of course, in the history, there is Japanese culture, and there are religious or philosophical aspects.
Having all those meanings, I think it’s a wonderful word. That’s why I named it Aunkai.
Even though Aunkai is not limited to a specific school or category,
we try to master those simply things taking into account the nature of a human body like two arms and two feet.
We focus on building our body,
including conditioning it externally all over the body like muscles, bones, and so on.
Once we are done with it, we do internally.
This is the most important thing and it takes a lot of time.
We have continuous tanren or training to develop our internal energy.
They call it "naiko" in Chinese bujutsu and I call it "naido".
This tanren is to deeply recognize those techniques and ideas by structuring your training yourself and working hard on it.
I think tanren is absolutely needed in bujitsu if you want to widen your teihen.
And this kind of…I would say correct way of training
including how you breathe and move,
is to learn to move your body from muscle memory,
to maintain that condition when you are relaxed,
and to recognize the condition of your body when you are facing someone.
At Aunkai, from the beginning,
we have given much importance to this recognition training,
to recognize the condition of your body as well as that of your opponent.
This becomes the core and it helps us develop our body
and adapt to other ryuhas such as martial arts, taijutsu, and jujutsu.
As we turn the body, we have different applications and techniques.
We develop those skills through practice with others.
That is the kind of training we mainly do.
We don’t really use existing, conventional katas or forms but instead,
we use the logic and mechanisms
that I learned from my past teachers as the basis of training and further analyze it as we practice.
When doing this, the way we move gradually changes as we step up.
and in fact, the way I move and how I am on the inside are completely different from how they were when I was younger.
This I call human experiment, human experiment using your own body.
I guess it’s fun and interesting to see how your body changes.
I think that’s one of the unique things about Aunkai.
Most of the people who come to Aunkai have various backgrounds and practiced different ryuhas
and they may have found a limit in their previous ways of tanren or training
and they may also have their challenges and questions as to what to choose
and which parts to learn more deeply.
I reflect on those things when I teach.
Well ultimately it’s what humans do.
I guess tradition is very important.
But I guess in the process of learning,
we may go through changes and find or notice new things.
Those kinds of things, I get to verify through teaching using my body and telling people.
That kind of free style or thinking I guess is the most interesting thing about Aunkai,
and I think that kind of thinking is very unique to Aunkai.
Conventionally, they have predetermined paths.
But at Aunkai, there are different kinds of people to begin with,
like foreigners.
As I also teach different things abroad,
I deal with people from different cultures and races, with different ways of thinking.
But when they take each other’s hands,
well that way that’s body to body,
I think they work hard in keiko or training regardless of language.
In japanese, "keiko" is like training, "renshu",
in English, you say "practice".
It can have different meanings but what I mean by keiko
is closer to what it meant in the bujutsu and budo from the time of the Samurai.
"Shosa" [所作, conduct] or "Saho" [作法, etiquette]
Those developed since the age of Samurai all come from the lifestyle aimed to learn those bodily movements through techniques in everyday life.
It enables you to constantly move your body logically and efficiently
without anything preventing and the body to function that way.
So keiko is something that takes into account those techniques
"Training" is usually interpreted as training your body,
your muscles as you have weight training or something training.
And practice is to repeat, like katageiko, repeat the same thing like kata,
I think that practice means to repeat those things.
I guess that training your body is the same across sports, budo, and bujutsu,
but actually I think the most important thing is the way you think,
the way you process what happens around you and a huge amount of information.
What I mean is that we have to think actively and comprehensively
about our nervous system and how our body works psychologically and biologically.
The reason is that as we do training continuously and repeatedly,
sometimes we end up doing it mindlessly without knowing what is important and what is needed.
So in training, in the process of intensely training your body,
there is a need to learn to slow down and relax your mind and body.
Normally, people may think of training as intense training where you challenge your limit like this
but it's not only that,
you also need to take your time to nurture your imagination through slow, quiet training.
This Aunkai way, well my way of thinking is very unique.
And in reality, in a fight, because things keep changing, you have to be able to process information extremely fast.
Of course, to think fast is very important in that kind of situation,
but in training and because it’s training,
I think you also need to purposely slow down and to recognize the technique of creating a relation between you and your opponent.
And I think that is also the fundamental technique that we have developed in bujitsu
to avoid a fight when you face your opponent like hyoushi, ma, and timing and all that.
That technique is like something that one learns and obtains as like another sense through hard work and time.
And when your body and your mind match, you will be able to control and use your body as you wish.
This is a very unique method of keiko at Aunkai.